Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Legends Of Tomorrow
episode six.
Jonah Hex video just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet so great.
Jonah Hex episode but just a reminder this
is the last episode before the big 4 night
crossover so there's no episode next week
but the week after that in 2 weeks is when
episode 7 is going to drop that's called Invasion
it's the last night of the big 4 night crossover
so just I'll just remind everyone what the
schedule is for next week at the end of this
video that this is mostly meant to be a Jonah
Hex Wild West episode great train robbery
great saloon brawl you can have a Western
without a really awesome saloon brawl so let's
do Top 10 WTF and Comic Book Easter Eggs I'll
try to like explain the stuff that's going
to lead into the big 4 night crossover to,
so number 10 Jeff Fahey rolls into town if
you don't know who he is, He's been on a whole
bunch of genre TV he's this really big B-movie
name.
So most people just know him from Lost but
he did Lawnmower Man he did all these crazy
sci-fi B movies, so anytime he shows up you
know it's gonna be nuts number nine though
the dwarf star alloy, so the minute they said
there was some really special ore and we knew
that ATOM was going to get his suit back I
was like okay this is probably the dwarf star
alloy, so that he can rebuild it.
But Turnbull kills the time traveler takes
his technology, so that he learns that it's
really special and uses it as an explosive
device.
He coats bullets with it which kind of remind
you of the Judas bullets from Luke Cage so
basically really bad ass bullets that can
penetrate Citizen Steel's skin.
So number eight there is enough dwarf star
alloy left at the end of the episode for ATOM
to power 20 ATOM suits, that doesn't mean
that he's going to build 20 ATOM suits it
just means that he has a lot of extra power
to spare he's trying to do something really
cool after he builds another, ATOM suit, but
number seven he does build Citizen Steel's
comic book costume for him.
So he'll wear that like you could see like
some of the arms in the face or exposed so
that when he does go full steel to look a
little closer to his comic book self you guys
can let me know you think of the design.
I think it's okay but we have to see him in
it like in action to get a sense for it is
kinda hard to tell just looking at right here,
but for those of you asking about the new
ATOM suit I don't know how much they're going
to change it from the old one it looks pretty
close but I think that the gonna use the opportunity
to make a little bit cooler to be give it
some more powers like he said he has a bunch
of dwarf star alloy to spare.
So he'll probably build some cool weapons
and technology with that.
But number six they know about the speedster
who is working with Damien Darhk they don't
know exactly who Eobard Thawne is or the reverse
flash's history with Barry.
So they're like okay were going to have to
some more research you get a firestorm go
find out all you can about speedsters and
what a coincidence they're the ones that heard
that secret message from Barry so that's just
going to play into the Legion of Doom storyline
so that just like the TV show's way of telling
you that that's something that's going to
be followed up on in later episodes like that
I can figured out right away along with the
talisman that the Reverse Flash wanted Damien
Darhk to steal like Citizen Steel is good
have to do a lot of research to figure out
what it does but is not can happen right away
and I don't know if it's can have anything
to do with the 4 night crossover because it's
purely dominator stuff that's not really Legion
of doom number five Martin Stein's brain quakes
I do think that is something that they will
answer like a big question about that in the
4 night crossover but he was right when he
said that he interacted with his past self
and that created some different timelines
in that's what he's experiencing right now
but as weird as that seems I do think that
they will answer that question during the
4 night crossover number 4 welcome back Jonah
Hex they save them from being hung by Turnbull's
men he's trying to get the bounty on Turnbull's
head they drop a whole bunch of references
to stuff that we learned last year in the
Jonah Hex episode if you didn't watch season
one of Legends Of Tomorrow.
They did a.
Jonah Hex episode when they tease the secret
history between rip hunter and Jonah Hex like
rip hunter long time time traveler had had
previous adventures with Jonah Hex.
So when they were talking about the big Turnbull
of that like the big battle rip hunter left
that was something that happened pre-season
one.
So like the legends were part of that that
was like rip hunter.
Jonah Hex thing but is just their way of letting
you know that Jonah Hex has a lot of history
with the Turnbull character so that's why
he wants to bring in so bad, but it was pretty
bad ass seeing citizens delete that bullet
with his teeth.
So it number three Citizen Steel stops the
train with his powers with her trying to do
most you probably picked up on this is just
give you a sense for what his power level
is like what he can do what he can't do is
not invulnerable like he eats the bullet there
are things that can penetrate his skin is
strong enough to stop a moving train, but
he probably couldn't do that all day long
but he is probably really hurting inside after
he did that.
So what I'm really hoping for is that like
the next big test is is that they'll have
the reverse flash try to phase his hand through
his skin will see if he can, but he should
be able to do it if dwarf star alloy can penetrate
his skin in the reverse flash is so fast that
he can time travel that he can probably vibrate
his hand through Citizen Steel number two
vixen and heat wave team up this is a really
awesome heat wave episode but I love the energy
that he has with vixens character.
She tells him she knows all about animals.
Now heat wave does not know about how her
totems work he doesn't know that her powers,
literally flow from the animals of the earth.
So it's kind of a funny moment to be this
really touching and then just letting you
know that they're going to continue their
friendship she's can help train him mentally
more than physically like just help him center
himself little bit but even though it's gonna
be doing heroic things that doesn't mean that
he's going to be a hero by the end of the
season he still going to be a very ambiguous
he's meant to be complicated they done a much
better job of writing his character this season
in this version of vixen is really awesome
to, so I just really love the two of them
together in a course number one WTF is our
friends in 2016 need our help.
That's the teaser for the 4 night crossover
so the schedule is a little out of wax just
explained that real quick next week they'll
be new episodes of Supergirl and flash but
everything else is on break.
So no arrow no Legends Of Tomorrow, then the
week after that starting on Monday, November
28 Supergirl is the first night of the crossover
and then each night thereafter is like the
next night so the week of the 28th it Supergirl
flash arrow Legends Of Tomorrow it'll be super
crazy.
And even though they have like the big dominators
invasion storyline from the comics going on
so each have like their own specific storyline
happening for Supergirl for Flash for Arrow
for the legends with in each of their own
episodes so like arrows getting his hundred
episode.
The not can a completely hijacked that in
all the Arrow stuff that they could be doing
just for the dominator storyline it'll all
work together.
Don't worry just be sure to watch each episode
of each of the shows that week of the crossover
if you haven't been watching all the shows
the season so during that week like even though
I haven't been doing Supergirl videos for
every episode I will do like a Supergirl video
through flash arrow Legends Of Tomorrow.
So don't worry I'll be doing videos for all
that stuff will be some more trailers for
that.
So it can be crazy let me know what you guys
think a.
Jonah Hex in this episode.
And what you think of Citizen Steel's costume.
I think a look a little bit cooler season
to season, depending on who comes back for
legends season three speaking of the schedule
I almost forgot, so they made this is huge
change to Legends Of Tomorrow in the second
half of the season this year so for season
two.
What's can happen when they come back in the
spring is that it's gonna be on Tuesday nights
after the flash at 9 PM.
So you'll have flash in Legends Of Tomorrow
and then on Wednesdays they'll be arrow, so
that means that they'll be no DC TV stuff
happening on Thursdays anymore it'll be Monday
Tuesday Wednesday for everything, so I will
say congratulations to G.I.
Jackie of the DC giveaway winner this week
is a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure to
private message me on the back of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
So there will be plenty more DC and Marvel
in the next couple of days.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything
I'll probably do a couple comic book videos
this weekend too, so while you wait for that
to post you can click here for the trailer
for the 4 night crossover and you can click
here for the Killer Frost Fash trailer, thank
you so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight!